ition une coupe du monde obtenue à
l'issue d'un match que les français ont
mené de bout en bout avec de superbes
moments de bravoure que jean philippe
lemaire et jacques gauthier ont partagé
hier soir avec des supporters qui
s'étaient rassemblés dans le stade
yves-du-manoir à colombes
c'est là que s'était déroulée la
première finale en france en 1938
mais l'équipe de france ne faisait pas
partie je vous propose de revoir tout de
suite ces moments d'émotion et ses
moments de bonheur du haut de cette
tribune plusieurs décennies d'événements
sportifs vous contemplent ici à cologne
s'est déroulée la finale de la première
coupe du monde disputée en france
c'était en 1938 soixante ans plus tard
par écran interposé le public vibre en
bleu blanc rouge
on sourit mes enfants on est bien sûr
inquiet mais on est vite rassuré avec
cette première occasion pour stéphane
guivarc'h
à
le capital confiance se bonifie grâce à
fabien barthez
on reste avec les corner petit pour la
tête si vrai qui vous savez
la mi temps approche et guivarc'h note
son duel avec l'appareil
corner à suivre zizou bis repetita
2 0 c'est la pause l'émotion ça donne
soif
ensuite en tremble mais heureusement il
y à fabien il ya aussi manu petit la
france chavire de bonheur
l'apport radioshack levi vaart est
extraordinaire et un match où tout le
monde va penser que la coupe du monde à
être élu comme souvent ses phrases mais
la joie et l'émotion atteignent leur
paroxysme dans ce stade yves-du-manoir
rempli d'histoire le relais est passé de
la plus belle des façons avec saint
denis et là bas quand deschamps soulève
la coupe du monde dans le ciel de
colombes c'est déjà le 14 juillet